A girl lies sleeping with electrodes
attached to her body.
A man and a woman are looking at her
through a one-way glass window
from the next room.
“Waste of time and money,” says the man.
“An illiterate kid from a stone quarry?
What could she possibly
contribute to the project?”
“Hardly a kid.
She’s at least 16,” says the woman.
“Come on, we’re making history.
First ever experiment
in collective dreaming.”
To her right is a screen
that takes up an entire wall.
The 311 participants
in the experiment are now all asleep.
Her poised finger jabs the keyboard.
The girl’s dream.
Shards of memory.
She’s watching her father at work.
The wooden skeleton of the great loom,
the finished tapestries
hanging on the wall.
Clackety-clack goes the loom.
The river floods,
sweeping her parents away.
The loom comes apart:
colored threads in the water.
The sound of hammer striking stone.
The choking dust.
The quarry at night.
Young people around the fire.
She lifts a bubbling pot of rice
from the flames.
Someone douses the fire,
and she lowers the pot into an insulator
they made out of clay and straw.
The rice cooks with its own heat.
The taste of hot rice and spiced oil.
But look,
there are strangers in her dream.
So many unfamiliar, bewildered faces.
And beside her,
a boy, about 12, holding
in his arms a large clock.
“Sync successful.
Activating stage two.”
Suddenly, the 311 dreaming people
are high up in the air.
The Earth dawns below them
swathed in green and blue,
punctuated by clouds and storm formations.
The most beautiful tapestry
the girl has ever seen.
“Father,” she whispers,
although he's been dead two years.
“Father, the world itself is a weave,
a living garment.”
Slowly, they fall through the air
and then they see ...
a vast swath of forest
veined and spotted with fire,
a gray wall of water
crashing down on a bleak shore,
drowning islands
ringed with plastic refuse,
beached carcasses of dead whales,
ant-like figures in their millions
walking away from desertified landscapes:
ruined fields,
destroyed forests.
The grief that envelops the girl
is so enormous a thing
that she can only take it in
through small, gasping breaths of pain.
She alights with the others
on a featureless plain
under a vast, brooding sky.
There’s the boy
with the clock in his arms.
The thumping of the girl’s heart
keeps time with the boy’s clock,
an urgent, rapid beat.
Tuck, tuck, tuck, tuck,
tick-tock, tick-tock.
Something’s coming.
“Warning: this is not in the program.”
Bearing down upon them is a whirlwind.
A chimera of storm clouds
and plastic rubbish and burning trees.
A monster made of hot dust
and angry water.
People scream and run,
but the boy with the clock
is standing still, watching.
Tick-tock, tick-tock, tick-tock.
“Why aren’t you running?” asks the girl.
“I’m studying the unraveling
of the world,” says the boy, earnestly.
“That’s what this monster
represents in our dream.
I’m an engineer and a knowledge-seeker.
Pleased to meet you.”
She turns away.
There’s a storm inside her:
grief and memory and anger.
She takes a deep breath
and walks toward the monster.
She stands before it.
A thin, dark girl
in a tattered, green sari.
Her hair is whipped loose from its braid,
and the end of her sari
unfurls like a flag.
“Stand back,” shouts the boy in alarm.
“Let me figure out the control mechanism.”
Bending her head,
straining against the wind,
the girl walks into the monster.
The monster has a middle
with a quiet place.
She sits on the bare ground
and looks up at the towering
vortex around her.
A rain of debris patters down.
There is a deep rumble,
and she thinks she hears the monster say,
“Why?”
“To learn,” says the girl.
“I’ve lost everything --
lost my chance to learn at school.
Teach me.”
To the boy outside
with the clock in his arms,
the girl has been consumed by the monster.
In the lab, the man and woman
look through the window
at the girl’s twitching body.
Alarms sound from the instruments
monitoring her vital signs.
At last, the girl emerges
from the monster.
The monster is retreating
over the horizon.
The plain is littered with debris.
The girl has cuts on her face and arms.
She walks up to the boy
and speaks to him urgently.
Then they turn
and face the waiting people.
“My teacher taught me,” says the girl,
“that the world is a living tapestry.
The wind and the waves are woven
together with the forests and grasslands,
threaded with the deserts
and snowy regions,
and all living things
are knit together in mutuality.
Although each place has its own pattern,
the tapestry is one.
As the weave of life
is torn apart in one place,
the threads unravel in another.”
She and the boy confer again.
“See my clock,” says the boy,
urgently to the crowd.
“It has components
with clearly defined functions
so you can adjust and control.
Treat each part separately.
You can tinker with it from the outside.
The clock was my orienting
metaphor for the world.
But the world is not like a clock, is it?”
He sets his clock on the ground.
Tick-tock, tick-tock, tick-tock.
“Come on,” says the girl
to the watching people.
She and the boy start putting
the scattered debris together,
and some of the others join them.
A structure starts to emerge.
An enormous loom of strange design.
The girl tosses
her insulating pot into the loom,
and it turns into a thick spool
of multicolored yarn.
There are levers for feet and hands,
and with a creak and a groan,
the loom begins to work.
The fabric unfolds:
a mesmerizing tapestry
of shifting colors and patterns.
“What should I do with my clock?”
asks the boy, picking it up.
Tick-tock, tick-tock, tick-tock.
But now the sound
of the loom is getting louder.
Dahganah, denah, dahganah,
dahganah, denah, dahganah, goes the loom.
“Throw it in!”
So the boy picks up the clock
and tosses it into the loom.
When it hits the tapestry,
it breaks up.
A fountain of silver glitter
scatters over the weaving.
Look, each bit of glitter has turned
into a tiny clock woven with the fabric.
The frantic ticking is slowing down
to accommodate the rhythm of the loom.
“We’re reweaving
the world!” shouts the girl,
and the dreamers find
themselves within the tapestry --
not outside, but in it.
Even the man and woman in the lab,
even you and me here in this room,
being woven back
into the fabric of the world.
Tick-tock, tick-tock,
tick-tock,
tick-tock.
Dahganah, denah, dahganah,
dahganah, denah, dahganah.
Thank you.
(Applause and cheers)